hey youtubers is Charlie so recently
loads of Cybermen were seen filming at
st. Paul's Cathedral so in honor of that
I wanted to do my top 10 Cybermen
episodes and even though Doctor Who's
not going to be a Comic Con next week
I'm still gonna do a doctor who themed
giveaway so I'll explain that at the end
of this video hello any new people if
you're just finding me for the first
time I do weekly Doctor Who videos be
sure to subscribe to get everything
I've even got some special stuff planned
for whenever the episodes start airing
so just explain the Cybermen at st.
Paul's Cathedral the rumor is that the
scene they were filming was an homage to
the scene from the season 6 episode the
invasion that's classic ooh season 6 it
was a second doctor episode the episode
is really notable because that was the
last Cyberman episode before the 1975
revenge of the Cybermen so they
basically went away for about seven
years it featured the classic Mondas
design I also think it was the first
televised episode to feature st. Paul's
Cathedral on screen
the only other reference I could find to
it being in an episode was in archival
footage during the series 5 finale the
Big Bang there was also a Mondas
Cybermen head spotted when ever Capaldi
was filming so I'm really looking
forward to some Easter eggs I wonder if
that means Steven Moffat is going to
retire the Cybermen for the remainder of
his tenure but either way let's look at
the top 10 Cyberman episodes number 10
tomb of the Cybermen this was the first
appearance the second doctor arrives on
the planet Telos with an archeological
crew that tries to revive them the
doctor of course defeated them and
resold the tomb so that episode
established the cyber mattes the little
you know computer mice looking Cybermen
as well as the cyber controller the one
that controls all Cybermen if this
episode were made today a Cyberman would
be seen zooming off into the distance
after the TARDIS D materialized just as
a teaser that they would return at some
point you can thank Marvel movie culture
for making that such a huge deal today
but TV soap operas have been doing stuff
like that for a long time the episodes
also really notable because it's the
oldest surviving second doctor episode
and the oldest surviving Cyberman
episode so even though these Cybermen
look way different from the other Mondas
Cybermen that showed up during classic
who they're all considered part of the
cyber empire that basically includes all
pretty szybist versions of the
characters I don't really consider the
szybist industry Cybermen as part of the
group but it gets a little confusing
because during the 2005 reboot the 11th
doctor kept
running into the cyber Legion fleet in
space the Mondas Cybermen also had their
own fleet so it gets a little timing why
me but number 9 the invasion this was
the last Cyberman episode before that
big break it's them invading current-day
London and marching around in the
streets like awful space tourists before
unit and the doctor took care of them
so there's actually a lot of interesting
non Cyberman stuff about this episode
from a production standpoint they were
using the episode as a test for the new
format of the show instead of the way
you see like an hour-long episode broken
into acts today the old Doctor Who
episodes were physically separated into
story arts so it would be like them
doing a series 8 episode and just like
chopping it up based on story acts and
posting those separately it's a little
weird but web series today do that all
the time the episode is also a bit of a
follow up to web of fear which is from
season 5 the year before that was
another modern invasion story that
involved unit and the great intelligence
so be on the lookout for great
intelligence Easter eggs in the series 8
finale
that's not airing till like November
December and they haven't said whether
or not they'll be taking weeks off
during series 8 it's totally possible
that they could just air all 12 episodes
of the regular part of the series
back-to-back and then just take a couple
weeks off before the Christmas special
but number eight the five doctors this
is like porn for classic Cybermen fans
it featured three different cyber
controllers even though two of them ate
it pretty fast the episode was a little
bit silly but that's kind of the point
art always gets reinterpreted so people
who watch this winter but first they're
probably felt differently it's so much
fun though the modern series has not
shown off Gallifrey the way the classic
series did although I do know a lot of
you think that the doctor will be
traveling to Gallifrey in the pocket
universe based on that scene from the
series 8 trailer just drawing the
association between the way that looked
and the way it looked during the
doctor's wife I'll totally say that for
a future video just because we could
spend all day talking about it but more
Cybermen moving on to number 7 earth
shock this was another episode that
brought them back from a long hiatus
this aired during 1982 during the fifth
doctors run before this the last episode
to feature them in a big way was the
1975 episode revenge of the Cybermen the
doctor basically has to stop the
Cybermen from crashing a giant spaceship
into the planet like an asteroid while
the nations of the earth try to unite
their few more Easter eggs relative to
series eight in here for instance Adric
name drops Romana and East base which is
just like the
universe its extra-dimensional Capaldi's
comment that they're travelling into
darkness makes me feel like they're
definitely traveling outside of normal
space but that could take them almost
anywhere especially if he's correcting
mistakes of the past but I don't think
that Vermont is going to come back but
number six
the Pandorica opens this was
legitimately a team-up episode so I
can't strictly call it a Cyberman
episode but I just love the sight of
that cyber head chomping its way after
Amy and then Rory splitting it through
the door it's a lot like the Daleks we
saw in asylum you know even though they
look terrible in ancient it doesn't mean
they're harmless
I always loved team-up episodes you know
usually it's the doctors friends coming
to help him but when the enemies do it
it's so much more fun but number five
silver nemesis this is the kind of
episode you get if you combine Doctor
Who with Merlin and Indiana Jones there
are three different factions trying to
gain control of one of Rassilon
artifacts the three factions being the
Cybermen a sorceress and a group of
Nazis this episode was from 1988 which
falls between Temple of Doom and Last
Crusade and even if the writers were
overtly paying homage to naina Jones you
have to admit that after those movies
any time you think of ancient artifacts
and Nazi collectors you think of Indiana
Jones the episode was also the 25th
anniversary of Doctor Who just giving
the silver and the title a nice double
meeting the producers even tried to get
Prince Edward to appear in it but the
royal family declined last year during
the 50th anniversary the royal family
paid them back and did host a party to
celebrate the occasion on to number four
nightmare and silver there are a lot of
mixed feelings about this episode Neil
Gaiman revealed that originally it was
planned as a two-part episode like a
two-hour episode so I think any story
complaints that people have can be
blamed on them mashing it all down into
a single hour I was wonder if those
really awesome promo shots like when the
Cyberman is revealed as the Turk plank
chess-like if it's written that way if
Neil Gaiman knew that that was going to
be used as a promo if you're not
familiar the Turk is a so-called
automaton created in the late 18th
century it was originally designed to be
the world's first robot that would play
chess against you and it would play
really well but secretly it was a puppet
device operated by a chess master hidden
in the bowels of the machine which is
why it was so funny when Warwick Davis
crawled out from under that table I also
really like the way they try to play the
idea of mr. clever the hybrid
organism created whenever the cyber
planner merges with the doctor it got a
little silly but the gifs of Matt Smith
were hilarious I think the real surprise
of the episode though was the Cybermen
finding a way to thwart the doctors
physiological incompatibilities and take
over his mind if not his body but number
three revenge of the Cybermen this was
the first time they were brought back
after a long hiatus at this point they
hadn't really gotten a big episode for
about seven years the Fourth Doctor
essentially learns about a plot where
the Cybermen are infecting people to
eliminate the threat of gold it was
explained that one of the Mondas
Cybermen weaknesses was gold it just
affected their organic breathing parts
this was also the story that aired
directly after Genesis of the Daleks and
the episode that immediately preceded
ter the Zygons two really important for
doctor stories it's really easy to
understand why people love the Fourth
Doctor so much just cuz there were so
many iconic stories during his run but
number two army of ghosts the Cybermen
in this episode were like hitchhikers
from hell bonus points to anyone that
can come up with a Hitchhiker's Guide
reference they basically just didn't
have the technology to design the void
ship that the Daleks had so they just
hopped a ride like an interdimensional
bus between in space in the parallel
universe so this episode was a little
different in that the Daleks and the
Cybermen fought each other unlike the
Pandorica opens when they were teaming
up these were the szybist versions that
appeared earlier during series two they
were all sucked into the void but then
they came back again during the next
Doctor Christmas special the one with
david morrissey that's also a really fun
episode that you cannot find on Netflix
which is kind of unfortunate but my
number one Cybermen episode the
two-parter rise of the Cybermen in age
of Steel
this was the reintroduction of the
Cybermen in the 2005 reboot with a brand
new design like whenever Star Trek
redesigned the Klingons for next
generation it was a pretty big deal and
as far as midseason finales go it was a
hell of a two-parter in an alternate
universe
cybus industries and john lumic created
the Cybermen as a way to cheat death he
was terminally ill and as expected the
Cybermen went completely nuts
supposedly they converted about 5
million of the people on that earth they
broke into n space a few times and
iterations of their design pop up every
time we see the Cybermen in future
series and just as an all case there's
the Big Finish story spare parts
essentially it's an audio drama that is
like the genesis of the Daleks episode 4
the Cybermen it stars Peter David
and in the story it's explained that the
original version of the Cybermen from
classic who were a race of people who
lived on a planet that was drifting too
close to their Sun and as a measure of
last resort they turned themselves into
Cybermen it definitely gives new meaning
to that phrase from the trailer life
prevails but let me know what your
favorite Cyberman story is in the
comments below it does not have to be an
episode it can totally be one of the
comics or one of the big finished
stories there are loads coming in series
8 so get excited we don't really know
what's going to bring them back yet but
I will be doing more weekly bonus videos
until episode 1 airs so just as a
reminder that's going to be on Saturday
August 23rd be sure to subscribe to get
everything
and just to explain my Comic Con
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video I'll leave it open till the
week after Comic Con just so you guys
have a chance to find it so right now
click here for my breakdown of the
series a trailer and click here for my
top 10 Daleks thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow high
fives
you